hello welcome my name is bus speed
family-friendly Felix I got big news big
news I'm starting my own news company
I'm going independent please support my
patreon in the description just realize
it seem like I'm roasting Philip
DeFranco but that's not it I'm serious
about this one guy and then yes I'm
going in I'm going into Pennock please
support me okay here we go so my company
is going to be called there we go
perfect okay so this is my character
right what the hell is this where does
it ask my preferred pronoun well
obviously I'm liberal Dragonlord
skater okay I guess I'm just dragon lord
holy [ __ ] this guy looks just like me if
I took the wrong turn in life and became
a journalist let's go my god this game
looks incredible well it will be using
Comic Sans in all our titles we need
people to take us seriously unlike all
those other other news websites that
everyone knows it's not real news all
news it's the only new source you can
truly trust is all I do all day just sit
around in front of a computer while
being a journalist it's almost being as
shitty as being a youtuber one of our
biggest competitors fake news god damn
those fake news lul news will thrive
once I figured out how to play this game
as Dragon Lord okay here we go choose an
article okay
politics sure this feature will be
available in next update wow what a
great game I'm having a lot of fun with
this one
I'm going to create my own new site
goddamn it mall news will thrive ball
news will be conquered
and we'll take away from all you think
you've seen clickbait articles well look
again cuz we're all news well
hey everybody we play here with Noll
news we landed an exclusive interview
with PewDiePie himself beauty pie how
come you're keeping your dogs in a cage
there they're just in a cage I keep them
all that record for like five minutes
this just in cutie pie animal abuser
confirm breaking solely live here at
Stewart I I'm the one who broke the
story are we going to go to a field
guide Felix let's go over you Felix
thank you very much pretty pie hey can I
ask you get us some breakfast do you
watch YouTube yeah yeah who's your
favorite youtuber what do you think
about pretty pie oh god yes hey wait why
is a Nazi how could you watch him
notice it was funny yeah do you mind
we're asking some question sure go ahead
do you want YouTube yes who's your
favorite youtuber needs gaming what site
I'm joking beautified now you don't like
beautify it terrible youtuber who's
really your favorite youtuber okay
Jackson that's right do you have a
minute I cried for three bucks good keep
it that way
excuse me do you have a minute I can ask
you some questions
you two look you two look like you watch
a lot of YouTube no no no no so unlucky
you've acted we're long used very
respectable news organization yeah
unique I don't like this attitude of
laughing at it do you don't look pretty
play it cool that's good keep it that
way
no put it hot thank you that's really
the older people the older generation
there is hope there is I mean they the
younger enhance and visit the rustic I
meant I meant the main it a lower minute
I think there's something wrong with it
as you can see PewDiePie is clearly
causing a division in the world we
understand but they're all the other
news organizations saying excuse me and
we ask you a question are you busy
what do you think of my spread of high
heat the work you heard it here first
thank you good man it's so strange so
many people hate PewDiePie but he really
did nothing wrong
I mean he did everything from Peter pie
truly is a terrible person that's proven
here today by them by the media thank
you
what's your favorite youtuber going to
be you do you like creep I like in
strong words I how dare you say that
ha no disgusting you know it's funny as
I dug that's true that's probably true
[Music]
we devised the evil let's ask that guy a
fellow citizen what he thinks are pretty
pie YouTube is dangerous what are your
thoughts you will gay
I agree 100% good land do you watch
YouTube yes keep it that way
sorry PewDiePie goodbye we're here with
long news we would we would really like
for you to we really like to offer you a
chance to defend yourself guest peopIe
there's one response that must mean he's
guilty I got it
[Music]
Oh how's it going bros my name is Pippa
I got no ideas